مراسل الجزيره هاني الشاعر هاني هاني في
ساعات الليل كيف تبدو الاوضاع وهل تم رصد
غراه
جديده نعم وسيله بما ان الاوضاع تشهد حاله
من الهدوء في هذه الساعه نبدا من حيث
انتهيت فيما تعلق باحوال النازحين خاصه في
منطقه خان يونس حيث مازال لليوم الثاني
عشر على التوالي محاصره اسرائيليه لعدد من
مراكز الاواء في المنطقه الغربيه لخان
يونس منطقه حي الامل ومنطقه المخيم الغربي
رغم التراجع التكتيكي ربما لبعض الاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه من هذه المناطق
لكنها ما تزال تعيش اوضاعا انسانيه صعبه
على وقع منع دخول المساعدات الانسانيه الى
هذه المناطق وفرض حصار مطبق على مراكز
الواء التابعه لوكاله الغوص الدوليه ومنع
دخول الامدادات سواءل الغذائيه ودخول
المياه الى هذه المناطق وكذلك معدات طبيه
لازمه الى مجمع ناصر الطبي الرئيسي خان
يونس وكذلك مشفى الامل الذي يحس حصارا من
الناحيه الشماليه والشرقيه وكذلك ال
الغربيه من قبل اليات عسكريه اسرائيليات
تطلق النار بين الحين والاخر صوب هذه
المباني وهذه الساحات التي ادت في مجملها
الى ارتقاء نحو 15 فلسطينيين تم دفنهم في
ساحه هذا المشفى بحسب الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني هناك اضرار لحقت في المباني في
خزانات المياه في مركبات الاسعاف داخل هذا
المبنى الرئيسي الذي قود عن العمل طيله
الفتره الماضيه وما تزال العمليه العسكريه
تتواصل في محيطه وفي الاحياء المجاوره في
منطقه حي الامن وهناك ايضا عشرات من
الشهداء في الطرقات بحسب شهود العيان لم
يستطع احد الوصول اليهم في ساعات
ايضا صباح امس تم الافراج الافراج عفوا عن
عشرات من المعتقلين الذين تم اعتقالهم في
هذه الاحياء من قبل القوات الاسرائيليه
عبر معبر كرم ابو سالم اجمالي من وصلوا
عبر معبر كرم ابو سالم الى قطاع غزه هم
114 معتقلا بينهم نحو تسعه سيده تسعه
سيدات عفوا الى القطاع جرا اعتقالهم من
خانيونس من البريج من بيت لاهيه من مدينه
غزه من منطقه الشمال ايضا ووصلوا في ظروف
صعبه جدا وبدا واضح على هؤلاء التعبد من
قبل القوات الاسرائيليه طيله فتره
اعتقالهم والتحقيق القاسي وادى ذلك الى
اصابتهم بخدوش وكسور وردود وايضا البعض
منهم فقد الذاكره بفعل الضرب المبرح من
قبل القوات الاسرائيليه التي تفرج بين
الفينه والاخرى عبر معبر كرم ابو سالم
جنوب قطاع غزه عن عشرات المعتقلين علما
بان هناك المئات ما زالوا معتقلين في ظروف
غامضه من قبل القوات الاسرائيليه ايضا في
مدينه رفح هنا جنوبي قطع غزه كانت هناك
غاره على منزل في منطقه حي النصر الشمالي
شرقي مدينه رفح ادت هذه الغاره الى
استشهاد اربعه من الفلسطينيين وصلوا
المشفى الاوروبي شرقي خانيونس كونه القريب
من تلك المنطقه وهذه الغاره طبقتها عمليات
قصف مدفع في المنطقه المقه الشرقيه وكذلك
ايضا اطلاق نار من قبل الزوارق الحربيه في
المنطقه الغربيه لمدينه رفح دون ان تسجل
اصابات في المنطقه الوسطى من قطاع غزه
هناك يسمع اطلاق نار وقصف مدفع في المنطقه
الشماليه لهذه المحافظه وقبل قليل افدنا
ايضا بسماع دوي تبادل لاطلاق النار في
المنطقه الغربيه من مدينه غزه حيث تشر
تمركز لبعض الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
منذ عده ايام ولم تتراجع الاليات عن هذه
المناطق باستثناء المناطق الميه الغربيه
منطقه المخابرات منطقه لتوان منطقه ايضا
العطاطه والسلاطين انسحبت بالكامل الاليات
العسكريه الاسريه للمره الاولى منذ بدء
العمليه البريه في ال 27 من اكتوبر
المنصرم وهذه المناطق دمرت و تكشفت بعد
عمليه الانسحاب حجم الجرائم الاسرائيليه
التي ارتكبت في هذه المناطق عبر العثور
على عشرات الجثامين المتحلله للشهداء
الذين يعني تم قصفهم وقن
نعموا عندما دخلت الى هذه المناطق وبا
بعمل التدمير والقصف هؤلاء لم يسعفهم
الوقت من الخروج من هذه المناطق وبالتالي
تعرضوا لاطلاق النار وتعرضوا للقصف وبقيت
الجسمين في تلك المناطق وتحللت بفعل
البقاء طيله هذه الفتره وعندما وصل
مواطنون لاول مره صباح يوم امس الى هذه
المناطق اعثروا على هذه الجثامين كذلك كشف
حجم الدمار الكبير في الاحياء السكنيه
والمربعات التي جر قصفها من قبل القوات
الاسرائيليه بشكل مباشر سواء من الجو حتى
من الارض وكذلك عمليات التجريف من قبل
الجرافات العسكريه الاسرائليه